this video is sponsored by Squarespace
an all-in-one platform that makes it
easy to make an amazing website hey guys
it's max with max tech Apple just
released the latest developer beta of
iOS 13 and inside of it we have our
first chance to test out the deep fusion
feature that they showed off at the
launch of the new iPhone 11 and 11 Pro
this is supposed to enhance detail and
merge multiple photos together in this
video we're gonna be comparing the
standard smart HDR shots to those taken
with diffusion along with that I am
throwing in some shots from the note 10
plus to see how much ever difference
this new computational algorithm is
going to make along with that I'm gonna
show you how to know if diffusion is
actually working because Apple is making
it incredibly difficult to know there's
no icon that turns on there's no
metadata info nothing like that and with
certain situations and scenarios and
even with certain lenses
it won't work at all and lastly I'll
show you one feature that you have to
make sure you turn off because with the
enable diffusion will not work at all in
any scenario and with any lens so let's
jump in here's our first shot taken in
lower light with the standard lens and
just from this kind of wide shot it's
hard to tell any sort of a difference
even from me but if we punch in one
thing I noticed immediately is the color
temperature along with that we have less
compression artifacts and the detail
does look a little bit sharper now if
you're watching this on a smartphone on
a small display or like 720p you might
not notice any difference other than the
colors so make sure you're playing back
at a high resolution preferably on a
nice monitor here's our second shot here
and this one is also taken with that 26
millimeter standard lens and just at a
glance like this it is hard to tell the
difference I mean I see a little bit
more sharpness in the salt lamp right
there but if we go ahead and punch in
BAM that is when we start to notice the
difference both in the salt lamp
especially in the background a lot more
detail and along with that with the
camera as well this shot is taken with
the telephoto lens outside it is quite
bright one thing you have to know is if
you're shooting outside and it's really
sunny there's a good chance diffusion
won't work at all in that case smart HDR
is what takes priority to increase your
dynamic range so if I shot this with the
standard lens diffusion
would not work but with a telephoto it
did work and if I go ahead and punch in
here there's really not that much of a
difference surprisingly maybe the
lighting is just too good the one thing
that does stand out to me is the texture
on that building where it says inland
imaging I actually see little horizontal
cutouts in the the concrete of the
building where is it's kind of smeared
on the smart HDR mode but either way
this is a very minimal difference in
this scenario now let's go ahead and
jump back inside where the lighting is a
little bit worse and here we see a shot
of Vadim both of them look great but I
can definitely tell even without
cropping in that especially like on the
hair and on the face a little bit on the
shirt we do have more details I'm
guessing even on the smartphone you're
gonna be able to tell the difference
here so we have more texture on the
shirt in the pores of his face and in
the little hair on his eyebrows it
really pops even as eyes you can see the
texture in the eyes and along with that
not only do we get more detailed but
also the color is more vibrant before I
show you when diffusion becomes
ineffective let me give a shout-out to
our sponsor Squarespace I've built many
websites using Squarespace and been
recommending them for over five years
now and I've tried making websites from
scratch using custom templates and
different platforms and Squarespace is
by far my most recommended method
whether you want to build a portfolio
site ecommerce blog or anything else
they have got you covered with great
cross-platform designs to choose from
and built-in security certificates and
SEO tools this means that your website
will rank much better in searches and
that's all included for one low price
meaning that Squarespace is not only
easy to use and fantastic looking but an
amazing value as well head to
squarespace.com slash max tech for a no
credit card required trial and to get
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain this one is with the
standard lens and I actually had to add
more light into the scene because the
camera app was going into night mode so
if night mode is enabled that means
defusion will not be working and it
seems like with the standard lens it is
a lot more sensitive so it goes into
night mode more often and also into the
standard HDR Smart HDR mode so with the
standard lens you probably just see less
benefit from deep fusion as we have seen
so it doesn't go into that mode more
often so here when I go ahead and punch
in you do see some extra details in the
hair and in the skin a little bit in the
shirt as well more texture from the
shirts but it's not as a dramatic of a
difference compared to the telephoto
lens now we have another shot here this
is also the telephoto lens and at a
glance I'm not saying that much of a
difference on my monitor but if we punch
in there is quite a bit of a difference
here especially where we have all the
optical stabilization the little
switches now before I show you the
comparison shots between the iPhone 11
Pro with deep fusion and the note 10
plus with its own scene optimization
mode let me explain how to know if
diffusion is actually working first off
you have to go into the camera app and
make sure that the setting under
composition which is called photos
captured outside the frame make sure
that is toggled off because if it's
turned on it's going to be taking
multiple photos and using the power of
the a13 to do that instead of using the
diffusion technique so if that is
toggled off right after you take the
image you want to make sure go and click
that little photo icon to go into your
photo role and you will notice that
after about one to two seconds the image
will actually have kind of like glitch
it's almost like a glitch in the matrix
or something like that so every time I
took a diffusion photo I clicked it I
watched it and I saw those glitches show
up sometimes it's more dramatic than the
other time so you got to make sure
you're looking for it but you will see
that shift so at this time that is the
only way to know if diffusion is working
now let's take a look at these
comparison shots between the Samsung and
the iPhone we're gonna start out with a
shot of this projector and right away
without cropping in I see a pretty big
difference first off the color on the
wall much more vibrant it doesn't look
so flat as it does with the note along
with that the texture of the wall really
comes out and the texture of the
projector itself it's definitely
noticeable now if I crop in the
difference is substantial first off the
dimples on the reel are much more
visible we have a lot more detail in
general second the embossed text on the
film reel is much more visible so at the
very top you can't see anything actually
on the note 10 shot it looks like it's
just smeared out I can't make out that
there's any text there at all now I want
to say that the note 10
is not about camera especially in the
portrait the telephoto lens shots or
portrait shots it does a really good job
with a lot of detail but with this
technique combining multiple photos and
then going up to 24 megapixel and then
crunching all that down you see the
results there that is doing a really
good job now let's switch to the
standard lens this is the 26 millimeter
and I'm not seeing that much of a
difference right away the texture of the
wall I do seem to look better on the
iPhone and the plaque looks a little bit
better but if we go and zoom in a bit
that is dramatic so first off on my
YouTube hundred thousand subscriber
plaque the no 10 plus has no texture at
all whatsoever it looks like a solid
piece of aluminum with maybe some faded
text that you can't read at all whereas
on the iPhone we see the texture of that
brush stainless steel on the lens we
have the actual texture of the lens cap
which you cannot see with a shot from
the note 10 and all of our switches you
can actually make out the text and it's
nice and contrasting
whereas on the note 10 it's kind of
smeared out and we just have more detail
and the shadows is all along this is a
massive difference in this shot as well
and this is one decent lighting as well
with all the lights turned on in this
room so there you guys have it our first
look at diffusion with a new iOS
developer beta so I really hope that
they keep improving on this it's already
a pretty good difference but they can't
probably make it better and I really
hope that they at least give us some
indication maybe a little icon where the
night mode icon shows up or something
else or maybe in the options or the X of
data I would love to be able to know
instead of having to go into the camera
roll right away and wait for that little
little glitch in the matrix like to be
able to see what is going on so thank
you guys for watching this with max with
Max a click above to subscribe and down
below to enable notifications if you
guys want to see more videos we have
some great videos right over there this
Mad Max with max tech and I will see you
in the next video
[Music]